[Music]
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on this oh
we're back
h3 after dark in the new studio
so hyped oh how's that how's the new
wallpaper look let's take it from me
looks pretty good it's pretty sick
looks very um
what's the word it looks
urban
um
a little gritty even you might say a
little gritty like us it's after dark
dating it is afternoon
nice to see you you know it's such a
shame to go the whole week without you
people only want to watch after dark
because and for enemies and for enemies
no off the rails nobody cares about off
the rails what can i do
no they care
we post off the rails and then people
start unsubbing
swear to god
i swear to god i was sitting there
watching the subs people don't like off
the rails i watched it too it didn't
happen
i don't know what can i do some you love
some you don't love we love when he
lives here this is not off the rails
today we are sponsored by hbo max shady
rays
um
boy do we have a lot of good stuff to
talk about today
how's everybody doing little check in
though first
pretty good pretty good we got pretty
good got it pretty good okay all right
guys thank you i'm so excited now i'm
still so weirded out that this is it
we're back yeah
i don't know
some normalcy yeah we're not quite done
with the studio because we just we
erected this
in like one weekend
yeah got him and so like it's a little
echo in here you guys can't tell
but the roof we need like um
some
something to absorb the sound because
you feel the echo
i guess maybe yeah
um
are we wearing this for a reason oh you
can bring that up already oh we're not
bringing it out i was just gonna try to
pretend like we weren't all wearing bass
pro shop hats yes we're wearing it for a
reason i am pro i'm joining the movement
i bought everybody a bass pro shop hat i
spent hundreds of dollars on bass pro
shop hats got your hat because
because i'm joining the bass pro shop
movement
i don't know anything about fish fishing
i've never even been i didn't even know
bass pro shop was a place yeah
but i'm getting the hat and i'm joining
the movement
everybody's got a bass pro shop people
just love the logo like it's just a
great logo bro i don't know what it is
but like every d-bag in the world is
walking around the bass pro shop hat all
of a sudden i'm ashamed to admit that i
actually do own one no okay tell me the
orc okay zach tell me the origin story
of the hat yes um well bass pro shop is
like this
freaking amazing uh
like indoor sports world they got food
and um i don't know it's just how long
have you had the hat uh probably a
couple years okay so you were before the
movement right you're an original bass
pro shopping
i'm an og yeah yeah i think it's
something else
i think it's like just these tik tok
douches uh trying to dress like normal
people i guess normal core yeah i guess
normal core if you will yeah they're
trying to be down with
they're working on yeah i guess so it's
like i could see that yeah
it's kind of white trashy isn't it
i hate to go back there but it's like
bass bro
we go down the leg fishing trap
some bass
right that's the end of the show yeah
let's stay on i've got me a big bass
i ain't taking no covid shot boy
bill gates made that put a microchip in
me
oh that's mexican
oh my god
that's i'm just saying white trash don't
do that
am i mixing up my
caricatures
okay okay what is today i have a
document with topics
okay this isn't off the rails you're
right
um yo okay so today's friday yes
before we get too deep into the show we
have to celebrate
with gabe you want to do it yes
[Music]
bring gabe
we need to celebrate
that it's friday baby
you know we friday means no school
means no work it's friday baby there he
is but get him up get him on my screen
oh my god i thought it was a sound bite
that what i think that was a sound but
it wasn't somewhere yeah
so friday means there's no school
what's today dude
friday it's friday baby
it's the weekend [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
is there work today crack opener
white pop baby [ __ ] it [ __ ] baby
jump jump let's go
[Applause]
iced tea
oh
what do we got planned for the weekend
gabe
uh we got um fight night tomorrow [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah baby
carpenter baby [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but until then it's friday
it's friday baby friday yeah yes weekend
it's the weekend baby [ __ ] yeah friday
saturday sunday oh
[ __ ] yeah well it's a holiday and it's a
four day weekend it is it is
memorial day
next week are you kidding me
did we just learn from gabe that it's
memorial day
baby it's a four day weekend [ __ ] yeah
what's on tuesday
tuesday tony tuesday
i was gonna say we don't talk about
tuesday because we all got to go back to
work and stuff oh yeah that
[ __ ] yeah
all right gabe
we're gonna um we're thinking about
doing burger tuesday you know oh mix it
up that could work too it sounds good to
me man yeah you work you work out you
seem kind of trimmed because it seems
like you enjoy your food a lot but you
look healthy
yeah i do my daily walks like in the
morning and stuff and you know
i just keep myself active you know
that's good
yeah
yeah that's good i'm jealous i mean i'm
a big fan i could have a lot to learn
from gabe anyway
i get sweet after eight and i don't eat
till after like 11 or 12. that's it
what about white claws after 12.
what it's good because it's better than
soda because it's sure less sugar less
calories so you don't have much alcohol
so do you drink white cloth when you're
thirsty or just when you're trying to
get drunk
i drink it when i'm thursday when i feel
like i i'm gonna have a soda i really
have a white cloth damn
quench your thirst with the white claw
all right yeah
baby yeah
all right well it's friday we're gonna
do our thing i hope you have a great
[ __ ] friday baby you know
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on baby
oh 500k white clock gabe you just hit
500k on tick tock right
i just made 5000k um followers of tick
tock yeah that's [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby
yeah got 500 000 more than we reach a
million baby [ __ ] let's go let's times
that by two baby [ __ ] come on baby yeah
yeah all right happy friday gabe happy
friday take care buddy
see you next week
all right baby see you on friday baby
[ __ ] yeah
with an angel
gabe everybody what clock gabe
everywhere you can find him on cameo too
small correction it is not memorial day
next week gabe what the [ __ ] get him
back on the phone get him back on the
phone
it's the it's the following week he was
a little complicated
getting back on the phone
hang on we just caused like a lot of
people
we have to clarify here we can't just
put that out there i'm getting back hold
on yeah we need gabe back on i need to
confront him about that all right stand
by because he can't give me a false four
day weekend baby
i feel like gabe's gotta correct the
record on that one
anyway white clock gabe's on cameo he's
crushing it there
pretty awesome man a cameo is really
cool for you know
gabe is making a living out there so
support your boy can i say i actually
ran into gabe in person oh yeah
oh oh my god
zach sent a photo of him and white clock
gabe together yeah i dropped it in the
uh our chat
oh i was i was like no how is it what
wait when you say our chat you mean
discord discord yeah
um you guys are not going to believe
this
this just happened a few days ago yeah
i was like what the hell
zach and white club gabe what's the
story here uh he was at a gas station um
and i saw him pulling through the car
wash and
he was in his car and like i was inside
paying and i see him through the window
i'm like i gotta go get him like i gotta
go take a picture with him wow i run out
i catch him right before he goes into
the drive to the car i'm like
dude there's no such thing as a
coincidence seriously
you guys are energy energetically
aligned seriously
that's crazy is gabe dodging us
now that he knows of his critical heir
he has not yet called back okay well uh
if i get him i'll i'll let you all right
well everybody is not memorial weekend
we were gabe was just a little gumbo
about his four day weekend which i don't
blame him because it's friday baby [ __ ]
all right let's move on shall we
oh well one other thing before we move
on just real quick you know how it is
we shall not teddyfresh.com you know
what to do
elo you want to give me the voiceover
um
uh i actually i'm wearing the cardigan
which
is one of my favorites and we
it was a surprise that it came early
like that almost never happens things
are always late
so we didn't get to shoot it on a model
so
um just so you guys know it is out
cardigan
hoodies
we got the uh yeah we got the color
blocks back we got the neons we got new
colors this jacket already sold out
sorry
honestly i was moved because
i love that jacket so much and it was
you know kind of like more expensive
than our normal stuff
and i didn't know what to expect people
believe in you
anyway head on over to teddyfresh.com
we've got all kinds of new fun exciting
things especially i will say for the i i
want to say especially i'll say we have
women's we're definitely got lots of
women's stuff now
underneath is like the tiny pocket
t-shirt you can fit a lighter or a coin
in it
the options are endless
anyway head on over to teddyfish.com and
see what's out there [ __ ]
[Music]
all right so everybody in the chat's
yelling at me saying that gabe got it
right he said next week oh he oh he did
but no but he said long weekend didn't
he
huh we all heard it somebody's gotta say
next monday can you go back he should be
in the zoom waiting room right now oh
let's hang it up okay he's back let's
just go straight to the source we can
clear this okay yeah let's just ask him
and he'll say
he'll say bring him on yeah give me one
sec so we're bringing gabe back to find
out to get clarity on when is the four
day weekend
gabe
what's up what's going on we need a
clarity [ __ ] yeah baby
yeah
2 30 stuff baby yeah on monday do we go
to work or are we not going to work well
if
it's monday is your day you know make
monday your day you know [ __ ] if you got
to go to work or go slow [ __ ] mondays
baby [ __ ] yeah okay
your day
make up monday make every day but is it
memorial day this monday
next probably next monday oh
okay gabe had it right the whole time
next monday is
what what's the next monday what's the
next monday coming up what's the next
what are you doing what do you mean
that's next week
all right
it's two mondays from now i'm just
trying to okay okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa where are we going we got to be
clear here because a lot of people are
not on this monday obviously this monday
would be in three or four days would you
say the next month next month next
monday next monday is the next monday
that arrives that's next monday dan what
are you doing right now then you're
being really you're trying to ruin the
show
the game is next monday gabe's right
right
right
i would call it two mondays for me okay
but okay so is it this monday monday's
from now it's so warranty though what's
the date exactly okay it's next monday
damn it's next monday gabe is right i'm
sorry again has a point because how
would you refer to monday that would be
this monday
it's the next monday you would say this
monday right gabe monday it's confusing
what phrases and stuff
so this monday would be after the
weekend
next monday would be memorial day
yeah
barbecue and
hot dogs and stuff yeah
see gabe's got his mind on the right
things dan is just trying to derail this
all right gabe take care we we love you
all right thanks a lot see you we'll see
you on friday thanks for clarifying
which friday next next friday next
friday right because next week's friday
would be next friday okay it's next
friday
next friday baby [ __ ]
thanks gabe
did we really bring him back for that
i thought he was next monday is clear i
think
because monday coming is this monday
welcome to the h3 podcast you just said
we'll see you next friday referring to
the next friday yeah because it's friday
today next friday is the next friday
this monday got it all right stop
nobody cares
[Music]
no we don't need to go that far
all right let's talk about something
real important on like this [ __ ] uh
wiki feet there's been a
full-on
wiki feed
mutiny by the mods of the website okay
i want to smell they've locked me out
they have uh banned me outright first
they turned off the rating i was like
okay they locked me at five and then
love love you want to talk about the war
you raged over the weekend
well yeah sure yeah give us the summer
well after you got
banned yeah
i thought no one took action i was just
sitting by at the side and
after a while i just decided to take
action in my own hands
the only thing i did was i rallied the
foot soldiers
i didn't do anything personally i just
called out all the foot soldiers out
there
and
we went to war fill out war with
wikifeed
and
since your page was locked oh you
actually weren't removed yet you were
locked to five stars
moved to a pathetic
five-star rating from
7.12
so they capped you at five they said
this [ __ ] is not going to go
about five so i had no chance of being
number one on the site until love took
action to downvote every other
person with above five stars
do you understand
the battle that was waged is this
illegal somehow
well
it was a long time he's in sweden yeah
and love made it very clear he didn't do
any action he just he just put it out
there
rallied all the foot soldiers yeah
well
so
weirdly now if you go to the top it's
zach and moses zach you're number one
which is like this was never meant to be
here's zach's number one toes i don't
know what to say man
those are joker toes
[Laughter]
so um
so i'm off the website ooh some of those
are graphic yikes graphic yeah they're
like from like gay porn shoots like
legitimately like they're not nude no
they're not nude it's just like a dude
in a speedo
you know okay it's all good
and i got news for you that means you're
gay i didn't but i didn't look i mean i
barely looked at it
it doesn't mean i'm gay i just barely
looked at it so who is gay who is gay i
think he probably is not me
not that there's anything wrong with it
um
so i'm off the website i was back to
number one when love waged the all-out
war to downvote everyone else and now
there's more interesting developments um
what else
so here here i'm just going to show you
i've got kind of the
is this is this what the state was after
you downvoted everyone or is this what
it looked like before they banned me
oh i can't see your screen but it's
daniel moses zach bobby lee
yeah that must be after so that was it
after they banned us
and then we actually there was there was
full-on mutiny on the wiki feet uh we
have insiders in the wiki feet like
guild which is like their top users and
they sending us screenshots
well i gotta show the screenshot they're
gonna know how i got it i didn't say who
it was okay we have spies on the inside
no we don't
how do we get this is a private mess
this is from the private forum
we literally have spot we have
infiltrated wiki feet at every level
we didn't do anything not only is so
here here's the inner uh
conversation going on not only have his
fans uh messes
not only have his fans messed others
galleries but they've also created
galleries of his own crew and giving
them astronomical ratings i'm sorry i
believe those feet got raided on their
own merit
can you disable the ratings on dan's
sword love and zach's page two it's
ridiculous
it's excellent
here's one i found evidence that ethan
klein's fan raided other celebs one star
to keep ethan at the top i did not do
that i didn't even know this was going
on this is completely unacceptable it is
one thing to ask your fans to rate you
favorably it's a whole different matter
when galleries are affected i am
disabling ratings on this page and
deleting all false votes made by ethan
klein fans hey i didn't do that that was
love he's in sweden this is an
international issue get interpol
involved
[Laughter]
holy
fit
they say i would delete the entire
goddamn gallery at this point this is
straight up rigging and he doesn't
deserve to have a galley for this [ __ ]
now remind you guys this is wiki feet so
it's not you know that's what that's
kind of why i like to wage war here's
because it's really
it's just wiki feet you know
i didn't do this though i i swear to god
i had no idea this was going on
you know
um
but here we we've struck back
and we've made up a website called
ethan's feet a place where i'll never be
below 5 stars
here this is ethansfeet.com
love was working on this
oh what happened okay
ethansfeet.com guys this is a real
website that we've made
what are those comments you can always
vote five stars yeah there's tweets
about it um
kanye tweeted you better have you have
way better feet than kim he said oh
interesting is kim does kim have a wiki
feed page she must
um
dan dan the hater said it would be funny
if abe got a higher wikifeed score than
ethan not on this website hater
hater asks dan
one's half like zero stars
and then even keemstar
said i would never say this on my main
but i love ethan's feet
[Laughter]
even keemstar bits
shoe size 22.
what i feel like that's the whole size
of my body 22 foot
you know but but guys the war so this is
kind of our shrine where i'll always
have five stars
but we're not done okay
i am not done
with wiki feet
it's not right first of all they don't
this first of all
they do not this i have a constitutional
right to be on wikipedia
they cannot refuse me service
they're stealing it
okay and so
listen
we have infiltrated wiki
we are making a push to get me back on
top
we have made
a very incognito account
called ethan kleinschkroth
we're currently at seven out of five
someone already gave us one stars the
haters are coming in but what we've done
is that we've edited it to make it oh
this one oh they're adding it
okay well here let me go to the get
people already adding okay so
ethan crine straw
they're all disguised
me what covered with the map you can't
tell that that's me that's ethan
kleinscroft seven out of five stars i'm
deep under the cover who's that
client
i know his name is ethan
and he's got beautiful feet
[Music]
i'm deep undercover
right here you can't tell it's me
bag over my head and that's how eela
likes to have sex with me
[Laughter]
oh people already adding photos so cat's
out of the bag but who's the second
photo
this is it i think that
oh that's that's a fan
oh somebody must have just added
oh
oh my god guys come on this is not a
joke don't make a joke out of this
all right guys we're up to dude we're up
to 7.42
i have never seen
a rating that high now let's go to sight
rating and just until i think they're
gonna oh
ethan's client scroll back number one
someone take a screenshot because where
it's 7.42 i've never seen a rating that
high that is the highest rating i've
ever seen we're back at number one guys
so we're just gonna keep it cool
keep it low profile
ethan kleinscroft
oh no
wait someone dared to give it four stars
i'm sorry
yo that that one four star rating took
away like a whole
wow a whole point value rough tough
crowd huh
so that's exciting so we'll keep
checking in on this
wow but we're number one for now
we are number one officially
um
so you guys keep me updated as things
develop
it's exciting
but keep don't tell anyone we are coming
and we are coming
i mean i listen wikifeet they they think
they can get rid of
they think i'm the true king it's like
you can't exile the king and ex like i'm
number one that's my seat of power
not you but uh clients crowd right i got
a chance crying scott whoever that is
yeah
[Music]
they don't know who they're messing with
and speaking of the fog horn of war oh
by the way there's all these wiki feed
memes that you guys been making let's
see
foot soldiers
wiki feet mods
moses lord of foot fairies dan the
betrayer
dead face down which is where he belongs
on this on this field of battle
tell ethan i want him to know it was me
dan that one's amazing
the color block down you are a [ __ ]
betrayer dude that is you
did you tank everyone on wikifeed so
ethan would be number one again yes
what did it cost everything they're good
these are good actually
wicky feed
what does that say palm day footwinner
just a little photoshop
game of toes oh yes
i am inevitable
uh wow and of course there's no such
thing as a coincidence with thanos
wikifeet mods foot soldiers ethan yeah
it's a great uh man renaissance is a
whole biblical battle playing out on
wicked foods right now there's no such
thing as a coincidence see i'm seeing
reports that wikifeet is down i think we
may have crashed why [ __ ] see that's
what i'm saying
no i didn't it's still up but uh
how am i myself the trolls beware uh
warning symbol is back up right
um i just resent that instead like
insinuation that were trolls
now wikifeed is definitely down for me
was that a sound bite what was that oh
my god i heard a clap of thunder
did you hear that yeah it's probably
just that or something
i heard a clap of thunder like a
biblical clap of thunder you guys
i swear to god
i think i'm energetically aligned with
you all right now
okay we're still number one
good
wow that spooked me there's no such
thing as a coincidence either we are
energetically aligned right now
there is no such thing as a coincidence
okay speaking of war you know zach put
together
this fantastic video submission for
crafts
mayo competition
and did they have been snubbing zach
zac's been having a little bit of a
meltdown actually to be honest yeah zach
tell me about
tell me about um
tell me about your emotions how you been
feeling just knowing that they've been
snubbing you i mean it it sucks like it
it [ __ ] sucks like and they you know
are retweeting other people that
quite frankly don't have [ __ ] on me
and uh you know not to put anyone down
like that but they don't have [ __ ] on me
and um it just like they're i'm totally
being snuffed
like no retweets no acknowledgement
didn't they like it they liked it but
that's just like oh okay you know that's
not enough you're right because they've
been they've been retweeting
other people's videos
i don't know so i've been trying to
wreck do we have the video i want to
show people kind of just who who maybe
missed it i'll just show it briefly
um it should be on the podcast twitter
you know we made this whole you guys
spent all day you guys spent a lot of
time investing in this and talking about
craft mail we ruined the uh the uh
asphalt it's all stained with my yeah
have you guys noticed that there's
permanent zack footprints on the asphalt
in the parking lot now
oh there's there's
from the oil and the mayo when he got
out of it if you go out there you'll see
what i'm talking about there's like
footprints all over i saw the uh you
really craft mayo you're not even here
it is gonna acknowledge so what i was
dude 13 000 likes i mean peace and love
nobody's holding a candle to that 200
000 views
so what i was wondering because
originally it zac there was like some
edgy jokes and stuff i was like you got
to take all the edgy stuff out because
craft is not gonna they're gonna want a
family family man
yeah
and so what i'm wondering is if there
was something edgy
left in here
well i went through and there was
absolutely no cursing whatsoever
hi how you doing today i am zach lewis
what's wrong with this video there's
nothing wrong with this video i think
i'm just too sexy man i think that's a
problem i'm going to show you sexy for
mayonnaise i'm the true mailman and why
maybe
they thought you were making a mockery
of the mail
are you mocking the mail absolutely not
i respect it yeah i mean you just took a
shot of it bro i mean that's respect
oh that's where the the toe shot came
from yeah
so it's all there's no such thing as a
coincidence
i mean i'm a sexy beast maybe that's it
you know did they think this was
appropriate like inappropriate maybe
they thought it was gross i mean they're
trying to create like a viral campaign
i mean it's mayonnaise you guys are
missing the point it's mayonnaise nobody
gives a [ __ ] about mayonnaise nobody's
on a mayonnaise page unless we send them
there they're gonna ignore this
masterpiece
but somehow look for a viral moment
we this is the viral moment
maybe they like well mayonnaise isn't
gross he's making it gross i mean i
don't think so i think he looks like a
snack to me thank you
it's an artistic
decision i mean i plugged the [ __ ] out
of them maybe the bite you took is too
small here i noticed you took a nibble
you're a little apprehensive maybe they
could tell you're grossed out here i i
mean no i thoroughly enjoyed it well
why'd you take such a small bite then
well i take another bite you do yeah
yeah
i mean look at that reaction yeah no you
loved it yeah i can't even pretend like
you didn't
this shot was maybe too sexual
this is sexual moment
was this a sexual moment
i don't i mean i was just enjoying
myself i was on a good time
zack you nasty boy bro i mean maybe this
this [ __ ] style
but you know i'm just i'm just enjoying
the mayonnaise like what what's wrong
with that i'm being shamed for doing
that you know right i think it's i don't
think it's right that they don't even
acknowledge you there's nothing wrong
with this video it's it's it's it's
frankly it's upsetting and you know
it's it is upsetting and you know like
we've been they know right like that
we're out here
like recently we said you know they've
reposted this other guys who it was a
fair submission i don't want to [ __ ] on
him but what i said why are you ignoring
zach 3
200 likes and no response from real
craft man yeah they they're just [ __ ]
with us they're totally no why are they
ignoring you i don't know
why
i
and all of their comments everywhere is
what about zach well i don't understand
literally i mean the foot soldiers have
gone through and through tagging my
instagram well the truth is though they
don't announce the winners until june
1st right right and then there's a
voting thing with the top eight
finalists on the 25th yeah i don't think
you're going to make it to the finalist
round that's i don't think they're going
to put you up there
it's so [ __ ]
i mean i don't know for sure but it just
seems like they are ignoring you this is
where we start our own mayonnaise brand
now that's an idea well i was thinking
about maybe endorsing a different
mayonnaise brand i won't say the name
because we won't go there yet everybody
would want us
no they don't i'm saying they don't we
don't need their permission
i'll just go full all out but what if we
create our own brand and zach is the
you want to start struggling mayonnaise
mail sale
oh yeah sign me up for some zail i just
i just it's a dream come true to have a
billboard and you know that's like the
one thing that would just well i'll tell
you one thing whoever wins that
billboard if it's not you we're buying
one
of you across the street and i don't
care and i'll i don't care the money i
don't care the commitment i'll do
whatever it takes and invest any dollar
amount to get you that billboard zach i
appreciate it i'll even sign a five-year
lease on that
the the world may be over by the time
the leaf
sometimes you know you got to put the
your money where your mouth is on those
billboards i really appreciate that yeah
but yeah this is [ __ ] that craft is
doing this like just it's a total [ __ ]
you to me and the show so it's like
here's what they say the judging
criteria is
passion for craft mail 40
the passion is there i mean that's 40
out of 4 yeah that's 40 out of 40.
originality 30 i'm sorry who else took a
bath thank you personality thirty
percent uh personality oodle oodles
there's there's as much personality in
that bathtub as there is mayonnaise true
they just better i i'm just i have a bad
feeling they're not gonna put them on
there because they they're just ignoring
it's just not okay and i know we we you
know threaten this
towards the beginning of the
conversation but you know they're i'm
gonna take a big stance against this and
should we take a legal action
i'm going to take a big stance against
this and you know what it is well here's
a big stance we created did you know
that craft mayonnaise has a wikipedia
not a good score by the way 3.9
one
yeah real craft mayonnaise oh look at
those we should say
the audience shouldn't necessarily take
this yet but just know that if zach
doesn't win
there will be consequences yeah
seriously there will be consequences
real craft mayonnaise i will say that
this is not a threat but there will be
dire grave consequences
if you do not at least put our boy on
the top
i mean i i looked i looked back at the
other submissions and like i said no one
holds a [ __ ] candle well like okay
maybe well let's not let's not trash on
the other submitters but like you
definitely deserve to be acknowledged
and put in the finalists [ __ ] a like
i
just [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] dan you said
he was like screaming he was like
genuinely upset
i was here at the studio
i was setting up on the stage he was at
the front of the building and i just
hear him going off i don't think he was
even talking to everybody really you
were just i was
talking about i don't know but he was he
was he was this was off camera well it's
not right what they're doing today yeah
it was i was i was very upset [ __ ]
living we need to march on washington
seriously man i i i i i'm speechless
because you know
it's just so [ __ ] because i am the
[ __ ] male man and they're just
[ __ ] me right now okay he was talking
to me we were trying to put something
together and he kept just walking away
well
i needed him to hold it up and he
[ __ ] craft me okay walking away while
i'm trying to put it together and dan's
like what are you guys doing out there
i'm like zach is leaving me stranded
while i'm trying to put together this uh
tv stand i almost threw my phone like he
was pissed he just kept walking away
like i at first i said as a joke i'm
like bro i really need you to hold this
up it's heavy he kept walking away
coming back but yeah he was back get
pull your [ __ ] together man whatever
happens we're going to make it right by
you you understand
you got nothing to worry about that
billboard either through love through
war or peace we will make it happen for
you uh i think and if you guys here is
craft mayonnaise wiki page so you know
what to do with this
show them show them we mean business do
we need presents in sweden in sweden
because of love like get a
billboard in sweden oh stockholm
represent representing stockholm
international exec number one
yeah
it's not a bad idea but i i appreciate
all the love and support from everybody
and uh of course you know you know we
got your bad this is this is outrageous
yeah they're stealing it oh oh oh hey
hey guys
just to be clear i see the rating going
up on craft mayo
should we make craft mail number one on
the website oh yeah for sure but then
they're gonna ban me if we make craft
mayo number one they're definitely going
to ban me
i mean that ship sailed at this point by
the way they can't by the way you're
already
the comments um
everybody knows it's us although they
pissed me off i gotta admit that the
foot soldiers are hilarious sometimes
and that's from
toejob69 all right job totally 69 was
one of the main haters actually i
remember that name yeah he gave it it
says he gave it a one star but i think
that's what we want but i think he's
trying to hate but he's actually
fulfilling the prophecy that we've set
forth right so this is toejob69 one of
our main haters
yeah i remember when we when we got
those uh
when our mole uh shared the information
from the guild with us i love that they
call themselves the guild the together
the toe guild or the foot guild
yeah i remember that that name stuck out
to me because it's
really weird i tell you what wikifeet
guild the toe guild you can banish me
but you will miss the days of battle you
will be like damn i miss
having ethan klein number one
i'm just saying i mean we've brought an
immense amount of traffic to their
website and amy and though i'm sure the
vast majority of our audience is just
participating in the gag i mean
five percent actually are jerking off
that's what i'm saying they're like oh
wow this is this is
definitely a
large number of people that are sticking
around
and i'm still number one
just an update thank you uh we have to
uh do our break oh we do it ready uh
we're actually at 37 minutes holy oh
frick time's flying baby so fast um
anyway you know
uh we will we will find you justice zach
everybody's wondering if towjob is
watching by toejob69 call in
if you're watching let us know i want to
talk to you yep
yeah i'd love to talk to joe job i think
he's keeping it anonymous though it's
kind of
oh we have more comments
um ethan klein people giving low rating
to everyone who goes near a five star so
he gets number one
seems like the mail site has been given
a roof for the rating since ethan klein
has only five of five
and it doesn't seem to be any more
gorgeous pages
of course
it's awesome i don't know but it's
awesome
all right
guys today we thank the people who are
supporting our lawsuit
hb is like hey don't bring me into it
dude i love hbo max bro this is hbo max
sponsor right here but i found out
something yeah ah hbo max is so awesome
first of all i love their app but they
have like um
how did they call it like sister sites
or or
like if there's an option they bought
other services i guess like they have
crunchyroll on there and all these other
services and it was like wow
yeah there's so much content the anime
portion was huge
and it's really nice
categorized like you have dub do you
have everything dude crunchyroll is
amazing if you like anime and like that
comes with hbo max and there was i don't
remember the other ones but there was a
bunch of other stuff too oh they had
like studio ghibli right
crazy
many of us are plumbing uh plumbing the
depths of our streaming platform
searching for something new to watch
looking for an entertainment fix and if
that's true for you boy do i have a
suggestion hbo max has same day movie
premieres that's true also of the
biggest movies of 2021 every single
month that's right the biggest warner
brothers pictures will be released be
available in theaters and your living
room the same day good i love it i love
spiel max i really do
um i watched what did i watch i recently
watched mortal kombat
i liked it i don't know
there was some
i hear a lot of people liked it actually
i heard a lot of people hated it there
was a lot of ups and i think i went in
with like zero uh expectations and i
loved that i was at home i didn't have
to like the thing is when you get
invested in going to the theater and
doing all this [ __ ] and making plans
then you have more expectations for a
film but because i was able to watch on
hbo max movie premiere on the and the
comfort of my own living room
uh i was i liked it a lot
they also just some suggestions for you
guys of the heights the musical event
that celebrates the meaning of home
you can't go wrong with the creator of
hamilton and the director of crazy rich
asians the heights
also space jam the new space jam a new
legacy
you knew and loved the original and now
the jam is back with nba champ and icon
lebron james
going in an epic ride with toon bugs
bunny tuned but why am i
tuned but why does it say toon bugs
bunny
i know bugs bunny as opposed to the
live-action bugs bunny yes
oh a live action event oh god
these titles and many more will be
available in theaters and on hbo max for
a limited time and at no extra charge to
subscribers release dates are subject to
change so get on in it and sign up for
hbo max at hbo
uh
m a
dot
a
x what the [ __ ] is this link then okay
let me let me do this again it's it's
it's in the description yeah you could
just say that hbo
mother f this is the weirdest link ever
bro yeah
it's h
o m
a x
correct
h-b-o-m-a this what is h-phil you gotta
you've got better urls than this
hbom
dot ax slash h3ma
bruh it's in the link yeah just go to
the description and click it one more
time because i don't want them to make
me do it again hbom
dot ax slash h3ma
hbo you can do better urls than that but
i love your service
thank you
love it
one more from shady rays oh jesus
uh let's see shady rays is a
beautiful sunglass company
everybody loves sunglasses right here
let's pull up their website
let's see what kind of stuff we got on
shady rays
oh they got these woody frames bro i
love these woody frames with polarized
sunglasses
lost broken protection
you like those woody frames what's going
on this oh look oh [ __ ] this guy's so
[ __ ] sick bro he's putting stones
like bro this is the kind of dope ass
dude who wears
shoulder shady rays what
who's got a puka shell why would you
bring that up
dan no shady raised people don't wear
pooka jean necklace
they're cooler than that
oh like a icy kind of fibery lens bra
and this guy's like on a hike somewhere
nice
hiking around exploring not pooka shells
you know six thousand six hundred
reviews
comes in all that colors yeah
oh that's the
lens cool
i love that woody one man
get that woody bruh
get a woody with that woody black ice
your performance
yo so sick so many styles listen let me
tell you about shady rays
um
my
here
live that air
looks in they're high quality shades for
way less than the expensive brands
they've got one of the best warranties
in the sunglass industry
and if you lose or break that your
sunglasses they're going to replace it
with a lifetime craftsmanship warranty
plus they donate 10 meals to fight
hunger in america with every order 10
meals
oh i need 10 meals i've been eating all
day
i don't understand why sunglasses are so
expensive you know
shady raise is on a mission to change
that they're an independently owned
sunglass company and they do everything
their way it's very rare in this
industry they make premium polarized
shades at a fraction of the price of the
big name brands so you're not going to
overpay anymore you can get the same
amazing quality with this warranty
stop it stop paying those crazy prices
bro
they start at just 48
hold pairs in hand try them on do
whatever
you know
48 bucks come on they also provide 10
meals to fight hunger in america with
every order
and they've donated over 15 million
meals to date
they stand behind their product and have
told their team that if anyone has a
problem they will throw profit out the
window and do whatever it takes to make
it right
they once got a complaint about glasses
they didn't like and the owner was like
[ __ ] dude and he [ __ ] shot he's like
start breaking windows and [ __ ] in a
rage he's like i refuse to sell glasses
he was so angry that this one person
didn't like it he flew to his house and
he's just with a buck in the glasses
he's like take them all
that uh your experience may vary
that didn't happen
look at my dogs is a mess look at my
document it's over here
and they don't see that
why is it over there okay confusing
uh so
change the way you wear sunglasses and
give shady razor risk-free shot we're
thinking we think you're going to love
them and if you're they're not for you
you can return them for free anyway
exclusively for our listener shady rays
is running their deepest deal of the
season
use code h3 for 50 off two or more pairs
at shadyrace.com buy one
get one free that means you can get two
pairs for forty eight dollars
redeem only at shadyrace.com where you
can find all their newest and best
shades use code h3 thank you
all right nice thank you thank you with
peace and love
um the chad is having a mini meltdown
my laptop do you think that ian is uh
not here or something i don't know
i'm looking right at him
i think he just had nobody's cut to him
yet show ian he's here yeah ian's here i
think we probably should explain
newer viewers might not know this but um
prior to the pandemic and the move to
the basement ian would switch and i
would just be doing the producing but
because we were trying to keep
the cross-contamination as minimal as
possible i was basically doing
everything over the course of the last
year i was at the house switching and
doing the audio and everything but we're
back so ian's switching again so that's
that's why
he's uh
back there behind me uh handling
business ian please stand up can you
stand up please ian ian stand up
[Applause]
there it is
we love you man ian how you doing lately
you feel good you all right
yes doing good
am i torturing you are you miserable
well people think i'm like torturing him
because he's just you know
are you okay are you healthy are you
being well treated i am not wearing
pants oh
um
can you at least answer the question
they think i'm holding you like capture
or something
no no it's great and i'm getting a lot
of exercise because i have to stand up
like every time you talk to me
so i'm staying fit
you don't have to stand up just use your
mic
okay i thought zach was going to play
the stand up
all right moving on
i just trying to talk to ian because
people think that like ian's miserable
and that i'm holding him captive and
hey but but we're dispelling that right
now you are here on your own free will
right ian
that is right yes yes thank you and are
you being are you being treated well are
they are you being fed
oh here let me get the script again
uh ethan klein loves me uh he takes care
of me he is a legend
huh five star man thank you you guys see
nice that was very everything's organic
i've been chugging the water all right
you want to talk about joe rogan the
reason why we're all here today
bro
does joe rogan have a wikifeed page he
must right
i've never visited joe's
page
let's see what kind of toes this look
this uh toe rogan has he looks like a
toe
oh brutal i don't know if
i don't know if we had anything to do
with that but he's been brutalized holy
[ __ ]
one star i doubt that we dance
you think so
someone's got to show this to joe
whoever's the guest i didn't do anything
but i find one star kind of suspicious
yeah one star is like brutal that's
brutal
love him
his photos are amazing dude's got he's
got weights on his feet
and his hands
love that
um so he has one star
um so joe rogan first of all
okay
listen
i didn't want to have to do this joe
but
he came after ela he literally called
ela an idiot
like i can't believe this conversation
we're about to have
um
joe rogan called ila our queen
an idiot i kind of feel like it's a flex
for me
like it's a big flex i could be like yo
joe organ called me dumb right
yeah i guess so
still have an infinitely higher iq than
banks
here's the clip let's watch it now
whitney cummings she's a friend of art
so you know i love whitney
but i don't know the context of this has
anyone watched this they were there
whitney was throwing these parties at
her house
now let me remind you this is during the
height of the pandemic people were not
even supposed to be gathering at the
time
yeah everyone there was supposed to be
wearing a mask the first time i think i
was invited i didn't go
second time i was like
i mean it does look really fun i haven't
done anything in like months
and she said basically it's outdoors
everyone's getting taste tested so
you know
um so i decided to go but i was super
paranoid about even going i was very
uncomfortable going to that party you
know just not that i was forced to do it
but i it was very uncomfortable
experience it was during the worst time
of the pandemic yeah the city was saying
don't gather there was no talk of a
vaccine or anything at that time right
and it was like surging and you know um
yeah so and we we had we were trying to
be very careful because of our son and
our nanny and and people in our you know
everyone i have
i have
employees to worry like i'm not trying
to give anyone covered in my life so
everyone there was technically supposed
to be wearing a mask and this was during
a time by the way when we were [ __ ]
on a lot of influencers who were being
super irresponsible going and not
wearing masks and stuff
so it's like you know we don't want to
be caught
[ __ ] being hypocrites you know ela
was there she was protected she was
wearing a mask it was outside
and um listen to what joe [ __ ] toe
rogan
sauna boy had to say about it
who's wearing the mask
that is hila klein olivia's not she's a
gangster look at her she's a gangster
meanwhile people have been listening to
this outside with a mask on and
everyone's tested that's what's so dumb
it's not so dumb
[ __ ]
first of all i don't know why he keeps
insisting on this war against like dude
again
even if it was taken yesterday why do
you [ __ ] care if someone's wearing a
mask you don't you know
why is he he he's he can't why are you
trying to prove so wrong
bro jogan what are you trying to prove
so wrong that you're a gangster
all right
he's too invested in like hating kovitz
it's like part of his identity because
he's a tough guy he doesn't need a mask
that's for puss is he yeah and he said
[ __ ] are are for matt are [ __ ] are
for masks i mean i thought he people
said that he was joking when he said
that but um that doesn't look like he's
joking so it's like a theme now that
i've seen over a few episodes well yeah
he so bill burke called him out when he
said he
around this time ironically where this
actual video was shot
joe rogan said masks are for [ __ ] on
his show
which is like bro i can't get over what
a dumb statement that is but bill burr
set him straight immediately and he's
always been trying to be like oh i'm
just kidding but he keeps saying [ __ ]
like that which shows that like he
clearly is not kidding a whole [ __ ]
time there's been [ __ ] [ __ ] on my
street walking around no masks
you know not
quarantining like the people that come
by the houses you see the [ __ ] you
know the same people that were going in
and out of the house who are not part of
their family still going in and out of
the house you want people to walk down
the street with a mask on
let's not start this job
let's not start this i love how bill was
like you [ __ ] dumbass yeah and this
is the height of the pandemic this isn't
really like a debate like a mainstream
debate i mean except beyond like total
partisans like queuing on people you
know what i mean
like the only people that were saying
don't wear a mask or people they're like
they're stealing it
wearing a mask as a symbol of oppression
they're just trying to control us so
this is like some really
alpha to the moon [ __ ]
you know what i i don't want to stop
[ __ ]
like my respect for bill burr went up
like times 1000 because
i just feel like
i don't know everyone like just kind of
like caves to bro jogging mm-hmm
and um he's alpha what do you expect and
bill burr is like
he was so quick to be like no no no no
no you don't even go there bill is this
amazing force that he cannot he will
never be influenced or cave like i feel
like other comedians go on there and
then all of a sudden they turn into like
uh
i trish always says this but like pick
me people where they're like oh joe
rogan yeah smoke wedge i'm down for
whatever you say or cool yeah [ __ ]
masks
but bill burr was like [ __ ] you idiot
love that here with no medical degree
listening to you with no medical degree
with an american flag behind you smoking
a cigar acting like we know what's up
better than the cdc all i do is i list i
watch the news once every two weeks i'm
like mascara no mess still mask all
right mask that's all i give a [ __ ]
about i don't care but even they say you
shouldn't wear a mask unless you're
treating a coronavirus patient no world
they didn't say that initially they
didn't say it initially no they didn't
they did and then it gradually then and
then well thank you everybody
this is like rollerblading everybody
[ __ ] rollerbladed and then there was
that one [ __ ] homophobic joke and
then everybody acted like they never did
it thank you bill and then a hundred
million [ __ ] rollerblades got thrown
into the [ __ ] ocean we all wore math
and then all of a sudden people are
[ __ ] sitting there but you don't have
the body type for it too
scrape
[Laughter]
man bill bird traumatized me though
[Music]
it's still part of me that's just scared
of him
or like just traumatized even though we
had like a good uh
second yeah yeah the follow-up episode
was great
[Laughter]
but anyway um
you know like dude really and then that
so it's like imagine it's like olivia is
awesome eloquent dumbass
god it's such a short clip and so much
to unpack but it's like bill said
i'm following the rules back then they
said you gotta wear a mask so i'm out
there wearing a mask wow big deal and
then now they say you know if you're
outside you don't need to wear a mask
it's pretty simple you want to talk
about who's dumb
yeah i mean there's a whole there's a
whole the cdc is like this whole
governmental body with scientists and
[ __ ] they just tell us what to do you
don't have to think about it dude
you're wearing the mask
that is who's wearing a mask who's that
[ __ ] who's wearing a mask who's that
piece of [ __ ] yeah i want to name her
can that person come up and like go
shove themselves
fine olivia's not she's a gangster look
at her in the front row [ __ ] it give me
all the copic
meanwhile people have been look at this
outside with a mask on and everyone's
tested that's what's so dumb
hey joe
okay you want to talk about dom
the the testing doesn't mean anything
you can get tested fine but it doesn't
give you the guarantee there's a fake
you know there's a pulse a false
negative yep you can get that and then
you would still give it to everyone in
the party sorry i don't want to do that
to other people i don't want to be the
one that's going to end up giving 20
people by accident because my tests
didn't work that one time
um give them covet and then they give it
to their mom and their mom dies yeah he
doesn't give a [ __ ] you know again i
keep going back the white house who's
gangster and who's dumb
dude i think that i think being a male
means protecting the people right well
i'm not giving i don't want to get into
like stereo gender stereotypes but like
even the traditional male stereotype
that he loves males are supposed to
protect people right like so what the
[ __ ] is protective about being a douche
and [ __ ] spreading covered people
by the
way the white house super spreading
event was outside and everyone was
tested one person came with covid and a
bunch of people got it and almost died
including the president
joe rogan's actually on the phone he
wants to defend himself
joe rogan
oh he's he's calling in right now
the joe logan experience
[Music]
podcast
experience
[Music]
what's going on man good to see you joe
what okay thanks for calling in um i
wanted to ask you why do you want red
yeah what's in that picture why you look
red we're like we're in like this wave
of like being evolved and not being
involved at the same time like
technologically
spectacularly evolved to the point okay
joe but i wanted to ask you about math
fly robots to mars and take pictures
okay so
can you i just want to discuss math if
you can tone it down when it comes to
like technology in our opinion here
but that is really interesting about
monkeys but i wanted to ask you about
send people over with metal tanks and
guns and shoot people thank you joe from
the other people yeah you can hang up on
him that guy is not
guys that was weird
i can't chill for a second just talk
about the issue yeah he just kind of
seemed like he had when he wanted yeah
what he wanted to talk about and just
wasn't really listening
yeah
you know joe rogan got was also in the
news recently for
saying here actually here let's watch
the clip he said something about
white man can no longer
exist uh here let me play it
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get to the point where
you capitulate where you agree to all
these demands it will eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk
right because it's your privilege to
express yourself when other people of
color have been science throughout
history
it will be you're not allowed to go
outside right because so many people
were imprisoned for so many years i mean
i'm not joking no well i didn't hear the
whole thing
wait great white men are not going able
to go outside
i didn't watch this whole thing
um
did you see this previous clip where you
yourself were just talking some really
dumb [ __ ] to um another comedian and no
one said anything to you and you were
sitting there getting paid and doing
whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah these straight white male are not
gonna be able to go outside
but you know okay let me let me finish
the clip because this caught me by
surprise the whole can't go outside
thing that seems to be more interesting
than
the beginning the part that he was
quoted for it's that crazy you know we
just got to be nice to you this guy
literally laughed at him there's a lot
of people that are taking advantage of
this weirdness in our culture and then
that becomes their thing their thing is
calling people out for their privilege
calling people out for their position
you know so your turn maybe activism
crazy times yeah most
you know what's funny to me well here
joe do you want okay joe's back on the
line yeah we got him back if we want to
so okay joe do you want to maybe have a
more nuanced
conversation about the
white male
experience
what's going on man good to see you all
right joe
joe i wanted to ask you about your
comments about do you really think that
white straight men are not gonna be able
to leave their house not about men who
decide they're women who want to use the
girls room [ __ ] roseanne barr everyone's
mad everyone is so mad and while all
this is all this weird personal
interaction [ __ ] is happening it's just
so i wanted to talk about one more
culture
the better ai gets it's like we're a.i
this was a trash
artificial intelligence
you're sure my mic's gone back on time i
know mine's on so i'm
joe will just plant this idea in their
heads and just like joe the ass is the
way to go because it's like open
okay
not listening
he just he has what he wants to say and
he's just he'll just talk about monkeys
and ai and [ __ ]
and he's saying that he feels like he's
gonna be silenced i mean the guy doesn't
stop talking i know just shut up and
listen i wanna have a conversation
um joe actually i want to break this
down a little bit because it's you can
never be woken up i don't know why he he
won't give up on this rabbit hole of
like the woe culture you know
first of all there's an inherent irony
of joe rogan a straight white male who's
being paid 100 million plus dollars from
spotify to go on
you know out to the public and like
spread coven misinformation for example
like i don't they're that's like the
epitome of not being silenced
but also what culture isn't just
targeting straight white men i mean
like i i i hear him about like wolf
culture but i always hear about like um
natalie what's her name what's her
channel i keep forgetting
oh you talking about contra point yeah
contra points
you know she's trans super woke um
person
and she gets [ __ ] on by the rest of the
trans community for not being woke
enough so it's like it's not just
straight white men and you know what
happens to people of color it happens to
to women it happens to gay i mean it
happens to everybody so like he wants to
be i don't know why straight white men
they're just so desperate to be victim
not all of them but like there's a whole
like pity party for straight white men
these days
and i find it very bizarre
i really do
that's the problem that's the problem it
keeps going further and further and
further down the line and if you get to
the point where you capitulate where you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to straight white men are
not allowed to talk
right i feel like he's just mad that
people keep
[ __ ] on him for his dumb tape for
being an idiot yeah he's not an idiot
he's a gangster which let's be honest i
get [ __ ] on for dumb takes all the time
right like i mean that's part of being a
public figure that speaks on the
microphone all the time sounds like free
speech to me
i'm not a doctor i'm a for people
right let them say their peace too but
there's there's certain things that
joe's been saying that's like dangerous
like the covet [ __ ] like i don't get
he's telling his audience don't get the
shot he's saying masks was for [ __ ]
he literally just like the other day
would you have to correct what mr rogan
said on his podcast yeah he said young
healthy people do need to get the
vaccine that's the whole point we need
them specifically actually to get the
vaccine
um
right because it's your privilege to
express yourself when other people of
color have been silenced throughout
history it will be you're not allowed to
go outside because so many people were
imprisoned for so many years i mean i'm
not joking no you better be uh you've
got to be [ __ ] kidding me bro you
better be kidding me i that take is cr
dude why why is that not the headline
straight white men will not be able to
go outside and i'm not joking
people think he's joking
that's right the guy literally laughed
wait i gotta go back it's a great moment
it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no i
know i know it really will get there no
he's like no i know you're an idiot i
know you are actually just really
believe that that crazy you know we just
got to be nice to each other man and
there's a lot of people that we got to
be nice to each other shut up you just
called my wife an idiot because you wear
a mask
during a [ __ ] pandemic dick
joe's a dick
and the dude has the most popular
podcast in the world he just got paid a
hundred million dollars real quickly do
his show for another couple years it's
really bizarre that's
him and his position he's not
complaining yeah complaining about being
silenced it's like bro you're like
you're literally making it you have like
the
talking you literally have like the most
listened to show in the world yeah where
you just smoke weed and ramble about
[ __ ] aliens and and ai and [ __ ] all
right well hold on hold on hold on we
actually have joe on back on the line
again is he gonna talk to us
uh oh okay so this time i wanna
specifically ask him
[Music]
[Music]
okay joe are you there
what's going on man good to see you
let's see he said the same thing every
time i talk to him so odd
joe okay
how is it that you're being silenced
when you have the biggest podcast in the
world
you're being paid tons of money by
spotify hundreds of millions of dollars
and it seems to me that you are uh
not being silenced at all in fact you're
being encouraged uh oh what how do you
justify that it's the [ __ ] human
interaction part is the part that we
can't get right it's real weird look at
all the different kinds of interactions
that we managed to successfully navigate
i mean people have obviously have some
kind of relevant business and there's
lawsuits in business and there's people
that get fired and there's all sorts of
problems with people doing business that
is very interesting but can you address
those
done right like business keeps improving
things keep getting no i didn't i don't
need to know about business
we treat each other like the way human
beings treat each other we barely get
what is
what do you think about the wolfness
we're not tolerating that [ __ ] her hello
joe rogan immediate reactions so it's
like when i when i'm he's not i don't
think all right
thank you joe all right we're cutting
them off joe i'm sorry all right
the guy is for a con for for one of the
greatest conversationalists of all time
the guy does not [ __ ] like yeah
he's just he can't even stick to the
place
dumb ass
i'm sorry i know people like him but man
that's just crazy to me
it's just crazy
black
very entertained by joe
um here's falchy correcting joe rogan by
the way literally the guy you have such
a prolific voice heard by so many people
that when you go and say young healthy
people shouldn't get vaccinated the head
the [ __ ] dr fauci has to go on the
news and be like this guy's wrong
that's what a what that's how big your
voice is i want to ask you popular uh
podcast host joe rogan you may have
heard about this
made comments about young people getting
vaccinate vaccinated it's getting a lot
of buzz he said if you're like 21 years
old and you say to me should i get
vaccinated i say no if you're a healthy
person and you're exercising all the
time and you're young and you're eating
well i don't think you need to worry
about this saying young healthy people
shouldn't get vaccinated just quickly
your response well that's incorrect
savannah and the reason why
that's him putting it nicely
yeah yeah you're talking about yourself
in a vacuum man right you're worried
about yourself this guy knows what he's
getting infected in likelihood that
you're not going to get any symptoms but
you can get infected and will get
infected if you put yourself at risk and
even if you don't have any symptoms
you're propagating the outbreak because
it is likely that you
even if you have no symptoms that you
may need to do like a translation like i
don't think joe rogan can understand
this language we need a translation like
even if you're a gangster
um the virus can still break into your
body and you can still be like a little
[ __ ] underneath but you know you're
still a gangster
but your body's a [ __ ] it's not your
fault it's not your fault
if you don't want your mom to be [ __ ]
then if your mom is a gangster she could
still be a [ __ ] just because you're a
[ __ ] underneath that's a really good
translation here here's another one
if there's a if there's a whole group of
chimps and the chimps they are they're
bad ass gyms
but like one of them see these chimps
these chips are amazing wow but one of
these chimps
gets this [ __ ] disease
right he doesn't know he has the [ __ ]
disease but maybe the biggest pimp chimp
there is the ped chip alpha pimp chimp
gets this [ __ ] disease from the other
chimp
right
does he have milk meat he he does eat
health meat but
not enough
i don't know
enough
not enough alchemy no
he ate some fruits or something some
[ __ ] [ __ ] some [ __ ] [ __ ] like apples
yeah did you guys see this clip there's
a meme of him going around too of the um
where's can you guys link the red photo
of him
uh yeah it's been the whole time
yeah that was one he posted of him in
his sauna the guy is like
the guy needs to give up this whole male
thing and he's got to be gay i'm sorry
to say that but i i hate to unclose it
him but there's no way he could be that
obsessed with masculinity and not be gay
there's no way
why is he so obsessed with masculinity
the dude loves dude i think i think he's
he loves dude i think he's deeply
insecure about his masculinity because
he's
such a little definitely
he wants to touch another man's penis
because he's obsessed with men he loves
their muscles he loves their he loves
their hormones he loves everything about
men he also it stands to tell that he
would also love their penis
and there's nothing wrong with that
but if you worship the maleness you all
the penis is like the is a huge part of
the maleness he wants to take a dick
interesting
science
maybe the octopus can speak you got
anything on that
i'm not a doctor i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
lee then infect someone else who might
infect someone who really could have a
problem with a severe outcome so if you
want to only worry about yourself and
not society then that's okay but if
you're saying to yourself even if i get
infected i could do damage to somebody
else even if i have no symptoms at all
and that's the reason why you've got to
be careful and get vaccinated thank you
dr fauci legendship
the man knows what he's talking about
oh here's his response since we're in
the joe rogan rabbit hole whatever he
went after my wife you guys you know
this is personal
it's like it didn't really go after me
but
you know what look it's like a perfect
storm for me yeah it's like the
anti-matter i've already and it's about
you yeah
i've already been so over this guy with
his
dumb
ideas
and then he comes and calms me down it's
perfect yeah it's a perfect storm so
forgive me for getting a little too
amped up over to rogan over here
science behind this is not so this is
him clearly this is like the thing about
this whole thing
this uh people being upset at me i
didn't say
i'm not i'm not an anti-vaxx person
right in fact i i mean dude
do people always say right to i think so
seeing a common thread here they they
coach them before they go out just agree
say right
it's like okay you want to be a guest on
this show let me hear you say right
um
he did say don't get vaccinated so i
mean
said i believe they're safe and i
encourage many people to take them my
parents were vaccinated i just said i
don't think that if you're a young
healthy person that you need it they're
wrong
that's not what he said though either he
said if somebody is 21 and healthy ask
me i would say and the way he said it he
goes no
no you should not get it
other people so you don't transmit the
virus that makes more sense so i'm not
young but that's a different argument
that's an argument never trust
the argument that you would transmit it
to other people
wait why is he saying that's a different
argument because because andrew is
saying
you take the vaccine so you don't give
it to other people yeah that's not a
different argument that's the same
that's a different argument it's the
vaccine it's one conversation you said
don't get it
but that's a different argument
so healthy person you're not that young
okay joe thanks man you're not okay if
you were a hot chick
then you'd say i was you i'd be like
you're on the ropes
am i backed up a little bit
37. yeah you're on the ropes bro i love
andrew don't say that to him he's a
beautiful
man anyway that was about sums it up
but yeah i feel like joe rogan just
turned into a place where every comedian
needs to go kiss the ring
right it's kind of like go kiss the
fortunately even though i not to um
throw shade at anyone no that's just
kind of like hey i love all these guys
they get invited it's this huge platform
you go kiss the ring
kiss the toe
joe rogan's calling in again should we
take it i don't know
i can't really go over that grade the
last few times joe wants to make one
more comment in defense of his show
saying that it's not just come kiss the
ring
he's coming back
the joe
don't you say what's going on man good
to see you what's going on bro don't you
have more all right joe what's going on
man you said according to the phone
screeners you said that you wanted to
defend your show and say it's not just a
place for comedians to come kiss the
rink go ahead it's because we're scared
i legitimately feel like we're scared
and i think when someone like trump is
in office we're more scared because we
realize how easy it is trump isn't in
office anymore you know he's using the
term regular person because he's
definitely not a regular person he's
very sick
and everybody knew who he was
he's kind of yeah
becomes the leader of okay
get the [ __ ] out of here because
[ __ ] idiot that guy has fried his
brain man
he can't keep his [ __ ] together no no no
no no no no
hey stop it
all day joe get the [ __ ] off my show bro
you have your own show it's way more
popular
what the [ __ ]
sick of that guy i'm not taking his
calls anymore
can't keep it
there's a comment saying this is the new
anti-vaxx saying i'm not anti-vaxx i'm
just asking questions yeah of course
okay what are your questions and by the
way joe never explained why he suggested
a 21-year-old should not get the virus
why
because they don't need it because they
won't die from kovid well that's where
when uh andrew said well you also take
it not just because of yourself but also
to not transmit it to other people
that's a different issue that's a whole
different other argument all right that
i never heard
all right jim okay
joe
rogan is a giant human toe
you know he's got only daughters he's
like in a fully
his house is like his wife and daughters
kind of interesting
because you know why because his nuts
secrete
uh
uh what's the female hormone ethan
what's the female move on moving on
estrogen yeah like man is naturally an
estrogen honeypot
everywhere he goes just estrogen
everywhere
all right you want to talk about kendall
jenner
this shit's pretty funny
kendall has the worst
marketing people of all time
oh vin likes that
um truly the worst marketing people of
all time
you know
she's been getting a lot of trouble for
her
apparently she has this 818 tequila
which everyone was already like why is
she making tequila you know
the [ __ ] does she know
everyone's getting rich making alcohol
these days you know that like george
clooney sold his out was also tequila
for like a billion dollars it's a very
trendy thing for uh
for celebs and even youtube uh wasn't
dobrick was making uh alcohol before
before he uh we need an alcohol
i never drink so i was thinking we
should make mayo but oh mayo you gotta
yeah wait wasn't that the thing too
though that uh dobrik um
he doesn't drink he doesn't drink at all
and he was selling alcohol yeah he's
like known for not drinking weirdos
yeah i hate that by the way when you
like go out with a friend and they're
like let's drink and
they get you all right up to drink and
then they don't drink how are you going
to encourage me to drink how are you
what happened to you
just like a
like a girlfriend not not a guy being
weird but it's she's let's go out and
drink we're all gonna go out and drink
and blah blah and then um what what are
you gonna have to drink and then and
then i find out like two minutes later
she's not drinking that's weird
weird bro
can you guys look up celebrity alcohol
sales
so here's kendall on the ranch you know
she's an agave farmer
you know
yeah she knows all about it
um are we having problems so what's the
what's the criticism here that she's
just pretending to care about tequila
in specific here
even that first one then like
people were like even the window is like
oh it's all like uh
oh that's so stupid
it's got like a trash can bag over it
like the window broke or something and
it's a temporary fix it's like you live
in a palace in calabasas
like that never happened to you and by
the way let's not pretend that there's
not like a hundred people with you right
now with cameras and lights and makeup
and publicist and bodyguard
just me on the agave farm right off the
camera there's like a hundred people
here guaranteed
okay i get it
they're so annoying i wish they would
just [ __ ] off
she's so annoying and what's even worse
is people that actually buy her alcohol
that's even more annoying to me
is people who are actually influenced by
this [ __ ] nothing of a human being
out in the agave farm drinking by
herself
freak
horseback through the agave farm
ew also
maybe there's more meaning to this but
eight one eight is like the area code of
the san fernando valley
it's like not a place literally not
portugal it's just a suburb of la yes so
it's like trying to appeal to yeah 818
is like a bougie area code in l.a yeah
it's like val it's like it's the valley
wait what's the story behind eight one
eight then yeah well that's why i i
qualify for this maybe there's some
other meeting that let's find out but
she's from the valley is the thing so
that's why let's find out okay let's
find out how to speculate
i think it i think you're right
818 is our home state california dude
that's so you say you're right then it's
like kanye it is that then brand is
presumably named after the area code for
calabasas there you go exactly it's like
that's what i'm saying it's just like
what that dude you seriously are so
embarrassing
well the thing about like tequila
farmers too is that like it's a really
like
it is a really rural rustic uh kind of
farmer
salt of the earth industry in mexico
like my parents live there and you see
these um
is it called no what are they called
these agave yeah it's called agave you
see these everywhere in mexico and these
are like real rural farmers and [ __ ] so
yeah she's definitely in that marketing
she's trying to project that you know
she's just a small town farm girl
just like one or two agave plants in
calabasas
yeah well they they use them often for
decorations right but um this fact that
it's actually eight one eight after that
valley [ __ ] calabasas area code is is
honestly insane that's culture
appropriation
oh my god look at the how the
connie also famously put the word
calabasas on a shirt so yeah but at
least he was like calabasas it says
calabasas right
who cares about calabasas this is like
[ __ ] i hate calabasas is not that
cool
i feel like they're trying to do like i
feel like that only works with other
places like new york you know when new
york is really interesting it's cool to
say new york
calabasas for you guys l.a is not cool
not like that well some place you could
do some places of value but not
calabasas
yeah santa you could say hollywood
that's cool hollywood i mean
kind of
that's kind of chewy oh it's juggie
okay but for you for you guys well
i'm not saying i would do it don't get
mad at me
calabasas is the is like this rich pure
white suburb of l.a blacklist is what we
called it growing up yeah i grew up near
not in calabasas but near it and yeah i
mean it's it's it it holds up to that i
haven't heard that name before very like
kanye lives there so there's also uh
hidden hills it's called a hidden bills
probably it's true well anyway it's like
a gated it's the whole city is gated off
and it's just there's nothing there
except rich people and they're making
yeah it's it's not like beverly hills
has like cool mystique you can drive
through their shops and stuff calabasas
is like so [ __ ] lame and boring i
hate it there
one starbucks looks really nice but like
it's a really nice suburb it's far away
too so i don't know what about this
whole thing about 818 okay
stop it
but i don't really care i'm just
pretending to be outraged
i think it's funny it's funny
i'm not going on twitter and being like
i mean the celebrities do the show all
the time they're [ __ ] just whoring
they're just like david dobrik was doing
the same thing it's like how do i make
the most money as fast as possible
but they are very tone deaf i will say
that because if you call recall
uh kendall's ooh
so my finger was getting electrocuted
uh if you recall kendall's pepsi ad
i mean she is the queen of being um
being out of touch
tortured artist she kind of sucks as an
artist
can't make anything good
we don't know what they're protesting
but we're in
tortured souls only
oh
let's go little dance little music
yeah hell yeah it's a festival up there
you know protests are wait so right is
it a protest or a festival
they're protesting like uh they're
pressing like someone murdered by um
the police and the guys yeah they're
like
[Laughter]
dancing for joy and [ __ ] 2017 this would
have been like uh when the ferguson
protests and all that was going on yeah
so they're out there like definitely not
a good time
no good times were happening during that
it's like it looked like a party to me
i'm ready to go protest looks fun
someone get the barbecue yeah
what is this song
yeah i don't know why you did here yeah
what's up girl what's up girl yo she's
like i'm not interested in the protest i
don't want to [ __ ] that guy
like everything about this dismissed the
mark
outfit change
no more [ __ ]
i'm going to come
trump loves it
oh and pepsi oh and then then the
protest just has like hot nice cool icy
bucket of pepsi
products like all protests still oh my
god
got diet pepsi pepsi blue pepsi black
what's up dude you wanna [ __ ] i'm gonna
impress you right now i don't care he's
like what are you guys protesting
here i'm about to i'm about to fix this
whole situation
semen is is another kind of milk dude i
literally am dying i'm this is so cringy
this is so upsetting it's just
people are so
people are celebrating that he sipped a
pepsi they're hugging do you understand
we did it we did it guys
he's i got to sip the pepsi
i can't deal with this do you guys
understand how bad that was
i forgot how upsetting that is
i think i was wrong the ferguson stuff
was in 2015 actually so i don't know
2017. i guess trump just got elected
they might have been referencing there
was like a women's the women's march
yeah i guess that that was more around
that time
but uh
regardless
can you imagine the whole parade is
focusing on this moment the one she's
the center of attention of everybody
everybody's holding the breath
is he gonna take it huh he took the
pepsi no she got the camera ready this
is the moment
he sipped the pepsi oh we've achieved
peace
i'm gonna cut the prisoners just got
freed
we're hugging we're crying
[Laughter]
i don't know i hope a lot of people got
fired for this i really do yeah i mean a
bro is well i can't believe this [ __ ]
it's the worst thing i've ever seen
yeah we did a video where i was drinking
pepsi and started slowly dying
that was right when youtube started
changing the rules and i remember yeah
arguing with my guy about he's like dude
you're dying from drinking a pepsi
that's not family-friendly i was like
blood looks too real i was like dude
this is [ __ ] comedy like what the
[ __ ]
here pepsi saves the world let's see
we just ended it with um
yeah
oh they can't put blood in the
creature production's new no skip all
that it's just the end sketch we did
back before covet remember when you
could go to the pier
[Music]
yeah youtube was pissed about this would
you like a pepsi
he didn't want a pepsi
[Music]
this is back in the day man we used to
get weird and wild with it we had to
sneak the pepsis on the roller coaster
and [ __ ]
we weren't supposed to be drinking
that's supposed to be blood okay
it's clear
[Music]
yeah the pepsi is slowly killing me it's
poison i think the point the joke i was
trying to make is like let's be honest
this is poison you're selling like right
sugared water to the point of it being
poison and trying to sell it like world
peace i mean let's be real about what it
is
people are saying pepsi lives matter
pepsi lives matter plm
[Music]
yeah the role getting on that roller
coaster was uh tough
they kicked us off when we got off they
were super angry
hila did my makeup my white makeup
you did a pretty good job with the
makeup
the water was freezing by the way yeah
really didn't want to feel it
if you don't live in california the
water is always cold crazy look at this
there's kids playing in the water it was
freezing it was like 50 degrees it was
horrible
[Music]
by the way i'll grab the cap so don't
worry about the all the littering oh
yeah
there it is
you're really committed to the bit there
with the fall ethan always does we
always that's what trish does understand
about me
i always commit
i miss making videos like that but
honestly
pepsi lives matter you guys are right
by the way am i still number one on wiki
feet
uh
let's see
ethan kleinschrom there's a bunch of new
ones oh somebody else has been doing uh
censored uh
oh so much doing the work yeah
oh
i'm flattered thank you so much
here let's see ethan crying scroth
yeah we've got a lot of work here you
guys been busy out here 6.7
yeah joe rogan toads
wow
who did that not one of you guys someone
else did that we've been doing the show
somebody has been pumping these out
wow everybody's playing along
nice
it says one says you shall not silence
the foot soldiers
oh with the guy fox mask
yes
[Laughter]
we're still number one here let's look
at the comments how do i look at
comments
is there nothing
oh there's a button at the bottom it
says comment section yeah i'm gonna get
the craft mayonnaise
craft man oh it looks like there's just
no there's just no no oh they're
reporting it yo you guys are giving him
a good rating
israeli man oh nice
zach mayonnaise lots of feet ooh stinky
oh stinky these are nice feet get that
out of here whose side are you guys on
anyway well you baby you said earlier to
to vote it up i guess there's been some
mis uh mis-messaging
mixed messaging here on this one
we're not going to tank it until they
screw right let's show them how much
they have to lose right exactly yo why
is there no comment section on schmidt
and schwein
it might be locked i mean i have a
feeling ethan
well
that's uh
can't we get some videos to watch and
stuff
lady wipes ass in the middle of best buy
uh that one's [ __ ] up i'm not gonna
watch that one
it's nasty it's too nasty because after
dark baby no it's tuna bro you can see
like [ __ ] on her hand
yeah she like goes into a best buy she's
like this really big lady
and she like is doing a sniff test
sniff test who does that
ethan does
i'm not no i won't say that i feel like
you've talked about it on the show
before on if i [ __ ] myself no not
no the sniff test i'll smell my hand
yeah right
but i think she i think what she was
doing is a little further like a poop
you know what this will be fun
ela you narrate what's happening go fold
dipstick
here let's do this ela will narrate
what's happening
okay
go ahead so go ahead yeah
explain explain to the audience what
you're saying i don't know what do you
see having her hand in there
gross yeah and that's awful there's
visible poop on her hand
and um
she gave it a good smile
horrific
she chat's demanding to see this video
all right
you've built it up too much it's really
not it's just disgusting here we go
let me refresh it
so here she's kind of it goes now look
at this you gotta love that yeah i mean
that's that's more than a sniff test
that's she is that's
right yeah that's a dip that's a
dipstick exactly
she's got some uh she's checking the oil
line she got some mustard back there oh
my goodness
was there visible poop on her hand i
couldn't tell or not ugh
why'd you show that that's gross
can you imagine seeing one someone in
public do that like would you call them
out like what would you do
i would i would probably just keep
watching from a spoiler
you know what i mean
because i would want to see
i would be really fascinated by it but i
wouldn't want to oh she's touching [ __ ]
oh she got i found it really fascinating
oh she's got paper she's going in for a
while did you hear about a restroom what
yeah you can do taking this so far wait
you can totally go to the bathroom
there's bathrooms
oh
oh my god there's nice bathrooms in best
buy oh her homemade or her husband and
child are there
wait where did the napkins come from she
grabbed it i think for something
you guys wanted it so here it is
those are just nice bathrooms in best
buy i don't know why
it had to be like this
that you know i second that there are
very nice restrooms in best buy so she
got you you know this oh yeah i have a
memory of good bathrooms and best buy
pleasant dump experience in there really
you know what's wild is your husband it
was just like what's up baby wiping your
ass
you get it all
is it like a fetish thing you think
oh what's up baby i don't say that
no i don't think so she just i think
she's just wiping her ass bruh
i don't know if it's a fetish thing all
right
what else do you got
[Music]
dude smokes
i don't think i can watch this either
you guys to be frank
someone said this is how kobe started
[Laughter]
this guy's smoking and then it hurts
that's on fire here let me
what the hell
[Music]
oh my god what a dumbass
he's lighting a cigarette or something
under his shirt oh like no he's hiding
no dan he's smoking a cigarette oh he's
under his shirt he's smoking a cigarette
that's right he's lighting a cigarette
under his shirt because it's windy
it's a cigarette
and he literally he liked his shirt on
fire i mean he really did it
oh my god dude you uh drugs in public
guys
whoa dude you're on fire
you're on fire
[Laughter]
what what
he hits it and while he's on fire
dude had his priorities all mixed up
[Laughter]
okay
decision making at the end there and so
so it's like a like a battle pipe
it's a tobacco water pipe okay yeah
smoking you ever gonna hedge up in the
goat we call it water water pipes
they'll kick you out if you don't yeah
although i mean things are different now
no they're water pipes
in california it's cigarette papers yes
exactly what a [ __ ] gun man that's
amazing oh we got a new tick tock joker
oh yeah this guy's pretty good we have
the whole joker hierarchy i mean hila
you tell me what you think about him
sometimes you get what you [ __ ]
deserve
wow sometimes you don't get what you
[ __ ] deserve
sometimes you get what you truly deserve
good insight i kind of love it sometimes
you don't get what you [ __ ] deserve
it's a good insight
like you know how new better than jared
leto
new action movies have this like super
realistic
dark
look to them so this is like taking it
to the next level um
this is realistic as it gets
here let's watch some more joker content
you know
whenever i think of batman
my heart is just filled with murder
[Laughter]
i might be my new favorite joker
it wasn't it
uh
136 likes
it went back about 30 foot
opened up into a big cavern
that was about is this a joe rogan call
what is he talking about
[Laughter]
hey joe you want to talk to this guy
joe you want to talk to the driver
conference call them yeah let's get them
online conference column
maybe joe can break through to this guy
i don't know
uh uh okay
all right joe stop with the pump just
just stop
[Music]
just cut to the point yo can you
interpret this video for me
what's going on man good to see you stop
it just talk to him
it's because we're scared i legitimately
feel like we're scared and i think when
someone like trump is in office we're
more scared because we realize how easy
it is for you making anything of this
you know i hate to use the term regular
can you turn up his death you're not a
regular person he's very successful and
very famous and everybody knew who he
was but
when a crazy showman becomes the leader
of the thing whether or not he's doing
good
arguing politically
[Music]
i don't know but it's just how he
behaves
it's who he is
that it's who he is like that that
freaks people out and that makes people
more on edge and so they're more angry
and they're they're they're breaking
through people out on things and they're
more looking to stomp out racism i get
it i think they're having a meaning i
think they're having a meaningful
connection yeah they can batch like
caves
marijuana has got two
bad side effects
one
oh man i'm out of weed
[Laughter]
marijuana
that's a real joker brain right there
step the [ __ ] down dude i don't want to
ever see you hear you say joker brain
again
this guy i i mean yeah there's no
competition there
let's see i mean we've talked about
everything it's kind of what how long
we've been going
uh
about an hour or 45. so we've got jake
paul left triller this was a crazy
development
jake paul was like triller such a
dumpster fire then even i am going to
leave it
got your hat
so got your hat i feel like this whole
lawsuit was a lot fueled by
yeah jake paul and this one guy who's
funding the lawsuit and so i think jake
surprised them and left to go to
showtime it's sent to the show vibe
and um i wonder what does it mean for a
lawsuit does it mean nothing
well i think i mean i could speculate
that the
that it would weaken their their their
motivation less excitement there
probably yeah
but i i my prediction for triller as a
media company is that they'll be they'll
be totally bankrupt in two years within
two years easily
there's they are hemorrhaging cash
on their app
these fights they're not making money
there's no way you think they're making
money and coming to me and begging
[ __ ] begging money for me just
because i watched the dumbass clip
gotcha i mean they're going after people
in instagram dms
right right right you think that they're
making money they're literally
threatening people on instagram dms
well jake you don't even work there
anymore apparently you left not really
imagine being too much of a dumpster
fire for a man that was accused of essay
by the new york times jake paul
who's already been denounced by puerto
rico after living there for a month
and jake paul's like trill is too much
of a dumpster fire for me
okay yeah
so i don't have any significant uh did
we ever even cover the the turtle thing
on the show
did we talk about the turtle thing i
think we did in front of me did we oh
maybe i'm friends yeah jake and logan
were
driving their golf courses on a
protected beach in puerto rico right i
saw a headline sea turtle's nest during
this time of year yeah and the
there's a clip of logan getting all butt
hurt that people are calling them out
can you find that really
because uh but but like at the same time
that he's crying about like oh the
media's so [ __ ] up everything i do is
scrutinized the [ __ ] puerto rican
government put out a press release
saying they're investigating it
no so
you can find that too and they were
there for like like a week before yes
happened like a week awesome one [ __ ]
week
let me tell you about banana let me tell
you about smashed protected turtle eggs
i'm a mother freaking blueberry
here's the video of them
jake's ain't driving a cauliflower with
threads through a turtle nesting area
allegedly filled with turtles
turtle eggs in puerto rico can you
imagine that
turtles are federally protected wildlife
dude can you just chill for like one
second and then jake paul's like jake
paul's like yo
trailer's way too much of a dumpster
fire for me
imagine being that [ __ ]
so and then there's then logan paul gets
pissed off because apparently he was
there too
i can't find my mouse
i can't find my mouse you guys it's
there i got it
well dan switched he reverses on me so
now i'm hella confused
no you said you want to go up
i'm used to going right
you can do that but it doesn't make you
go any direction you want you know what
it's easy to change yeah but if i'm
thank you zach if i go right with it the
tv is on my left it doesn't make any
sense you know what it's in your brain
are you breaking open chips
oh my god
i'm a sick [ __ ] guy like a quick [ __ ] uh
[Music]
all right guys back baby part of the
episode all right i don't know we have a
lot of new people i feel like on the
show i don't know how many of you
remember
that
then
he's got a chip problem
and he starts crunching during the show
every time i will call him he's eating
something like dude can you not eat
during the show i am starving but what
kind of show is this everyone is chewing
it's the back half this is a notorious
back off
we put up we put our hair down we start
eating it's a nightmare
look at this official statement from the
department of natural
and environmental resources i need that
harsh me
for the chips oh that's a good idea do
we have the hush me
we can test it with chip eating
yeah grab your i know where it is going
to try it with chipping
yeah
well we just moved so
so they said this is a statement from
secretary rafael
machado
i have ordered an investigation to
determine the circumstance surrounding
the use of two motor vehicles on beaches
that are presumed to be in puerto rico
some media published a video of an
influencer jake paul on a motor vehicle
on the beach
an activity that is prohibited apart
from law enforcement agencies although
the video does not establish where or
when it was carried out dner reminds
citizens that this type of activity is
prohibited by law to protect the
environment and species that can nest or
live in the beaches those who violate
the law face fines and other penalties i
call for us to share the beaches and
other natural resources considering
their conserve conservation and
preservation likewise we applaud that
our citizens become eyes and spokesman
for the possible environmental damage
that some people cause due to ignorance
or unscrupulousness
we don't care
yeah that's clear
that's clear so either you can do a chip
test
very convenient
are we off the rails
here and then there's something else did
you get the video logan complaining
how did i do this
yeah no it doesn't feel right
here let me help you
so it's not the most comfortable that
right here
all right yeah so you want to put a chip
in there and then go up to the
microphone
that looks funny i can definitely hear
it in the headphones
i can hear it yeah of course
sure
i can pretty sure i hear it
try talking into the mic you looked like
you were maybe not hearing
no i was laughing because it sounded
funny
hush me guys
on what does it matter yeah i guess i
don't really know if the if the on
matters for the noise cancellation
anything
i'm crashing pretty loud
is it
i mean it's muffled a little muffled
it's muffled
[Laughter]
yeah i can hear it you can definitely
hear it we can't even i can't even mute
a chip
[Laughter]
that's fine
so wait did you find the video of logan
crying about being misrepresented
i'm looking for her now i mean i see one
where he shared the security guards
talking about it
[Music]
was that no i saw i think it was on his
pockets like i'm sick of the media
taking me out of context wait
out of context for running over a turtle
those people don't know what those
turtles did
before the camera they had a comment
they'd added that [ __ ] coming no he
was saying there was no turtles on the
beach and other people were driving
their cars he was like
he was just saying that he's been framed
and stuff
you're [ __ ] savage you gotta do it
well i've got nothing left on my
document so
you guys got any questions
anything interesting coming from the uh
chat
should we do a little q a
uh the chat
i was in the chat when we were talking
about rogan a lot
asking
um
like what you think about whitney not
standing up for you in that clip
um
i don't know i didn't really care
because i feel like she was probably
just nervous in that situation
um i mean it's awkward i think it's kind
of awkward and
like
she's been always really nice to me
they're munching chips he was having an
emotional moment dancing
i'm stress eating
sorry so
i don't feel like really
betrayed or something i think it's
whatever it's just that
she was probably just nervous and like
didn't she doesn't want to set it
i think she didn't really hear it i
think it just kind of rolled past her
mm-hmm
yeah she's nice we love whitney i think
joe's just a douche i mean it would have
been nice if whitney was like oh this is
from like months ago but it doesn't
really matter because honestly
shut the [ __ ] up regardless yeah
yeah
i see people saying posty
all right there was a clip of him on
steve they're saying that yeah we can
watch it
let's watch that
um
oh yeah
oh you know this wasn't this was
definitely inspired by post right for
sure
i did the teddy the polar bear with the
post malone tattoo for sure
there is no such thing as a coincidence
speaking of that
um yeah so po you guys remember
a lot of people i guess
remembered my comment about how i was
kind of
falling out of touch with post
um
and so he commented on it
on stevo's podcast also a friend of the
show
small world huh
yeah dude
and here's the clip
um
ethan just uh
he said he's he just i guess this was
like yesterday or the day before he said
he was sad because we don't
talk anymore oh yeah and it's so funny
you mentioned him i just got his number
back again so i'm gonna text him tonight
he's he's an incredible guy and ela's
the most amazing person
yeah i i [ __ ] love that dude man
love both those guys that's really sweet
steve was a nice guest
stevo's such a cool interesting guy i i
honestly love stevo so much
and this is new or from i think he must
have like backlogged it or something huh
did this just come out i feel like it
must have just come out cause he said
yeah stevo must have been sitting on
that for a hot minute
he was sitting on that for like a month
stevo's wild ride
that's cool he's actually in person
though because mine was over a zoom
because of the
yeah he was supposed to one day ago
um
genuinely love both those guys
yeah
i feel like i wish i was and ethan just
uh
he said he's he just i guess this was
yeah
so you guys probably want to hear if i
heard from post or not
i guess yeah dude
well like he i didn't but
but again it's like
see i didn't want to talk about i didn't
want to talk about because i seem like a
little [ __ ] ass whiny [ __ ] i'm not
trying to make a big deal out of it
um
dude i don't i do that thing too where i
don't text people uh i don't text people
so i get it
but it's nice to hear them say nice
things about me because i really respect
and love both those guys too so it's
nice
yeah post is uh cool dude
he's really a sweetheart he's really
just such as we are and steve was such
an interesting cool guy
he was um
post was one of the earliest guests
on the show when i started working for
you guys right um and i had no idea who
he was and i guess it was before he had
really catapulted into that's true
because our sound guy alex at the time
also didn't know who he was right so
interesting yeah um
yeah i think it was like later that year
that his album came out and he became
one of the biggest artists in the world
but um you know i was i you know i had
just started working for you guys and he
was
so cool so chill just uh yeah it was
super fun hung out with us after the
show and everything he's
just a really down-to-earth dude
his one of his assistants texted me and
was like hey
i work with post uh
let me get your number
and i was like here's my number
and that's it that's all that's all that
happened
i don't know how to tell the story
without seeming like a little bit so
i found it really fascinating i don't
want to make it sound like
desperate or anything
[Laughter]
you know
so that's that
but anyway it was really nice to see
them talk nice about me love those two
[ __ ] there's people spamming uh
ms kiff in the uh chat oh what about
miss kif i'm talking with him we want to
do something with him yeah i guess he's
in uh
he was in la he left but he'll be back
again oh okay
and then i was thinking we could oh you
know love had a really good idea that we
would buy a rare pokemon box like a
super rare 10 000 pokemon box and open
it with him
he's very into that or maybe you know be
crazy you know people do the thing where
they cut the cards in half
that would be really charged that'd be
powerful
why do people do that
i guess they it's just exciting like
they take one pack out of the box and go
okay i'm gonna cut this one in half
it's like it's like a reverse
it's exciting because you're like oh i
hope i didn't [ __ ] cut up a really
valuable one yeah
so it's like a game of risk
it's russian roulette with pokemon cards
pokemon cards are interesting of your
life
interesting
um
people what else were people asking
about oh bella um she i guess we we
moved there to next week right
it's not it's not [ __ ] yet it's not
official it'll it'll happen eventually
i'm sure but uh it might be next week it
might be later so got moved to next week
but we haven't confirmed it so we don't
know what busy lady i swear to god
you're already big timing me
you know what i'm saying like and then
post them alone everyone drops me the
minute they they go superstar like her
video was so successful
it was amazing
um i was really happy for her that her
video did so well but it's like oh big
time ethan no i don't think so everybody
everybody big times ethan
i don't think it's like that's not true
little stupid ethan pathetic ethan
everybody hates him people asking for an
update on your diet
a lot of comments about your weight loss
lately it's definitely noticeable and
i'm not not just saying that
uh
well thank you actually um
that's funny i was just with him
yesterday
i like my trainer actually he's a nice
guy we have over nice
80 million
80 million dude her video is crushing it
bro wow that's awesome i'm soaked for
fair
i thought it was good i don't know i
thought i thought it was pretty cool
look good she sounds good i don't get
you know
but uh
i'll just be sitting here in my stupid
[ __ ] podcast studio small time ethan
uh we're talking about my weight loss
i'm not going on the scale i refuse to
get on the scale yeah you don't need to
i have a bad feeling if i got on that
scale it's going to be 240 fat ass and
then i'll lose all my
but you guys tell me i don't know
well everyone i agree that you look like
you lost weight there is a big part of
me still that doesn't believe you guys
no in your face especially there's a big
part of me that's like they're just
because so many times
i've said i wanted to lose weight and
i'm weighing myself and i know i'm not
losing weight and and then people say oh
you lose weight because they're telling
you what you want to hear so that's what
so no cookies for you
not correct chris
not in this case i don't think i mean
you were um with peace and love you were
i was big you were approaching the
triple chin you're down to a double now
the number of pins has have been reduced
i mean so it's hard to know because i i
have to say this about myself i was
getting
massive
for a minute there like 240 i was like
whoa that's crazy i heard you talking to
trey shy about how cause she's
it it is true that your body is just
weird a little like big ass hips
yeah and i was there with you we were
trying to shop pants and it's like
it doesn't look like ethan is big but um
you can't buy the stuff you want to buy
and that sucks
thank you
it sucks yeah thank you so much
i was i was asking ila last night i was
like you know how alex jones is before
and afters so there's fat ethan here i'm
going to pull up my shirt i don't care
there's fat ethan or the husky than alex
jones ethan
and then there's fat
do you prefer fat either
because i feel like these these two body
types are real some of these just carry
their weight like this
dude some dudes literally carry all
their weight like this like and they
just cruise around like this and they
look fine
but my body is like this yeah
so do you like fat ethan or husky
vanilla because i can be whatever you
want
um
i like fatty thin you do
you don't like alex jones eat them
congratulations you're fat
no
look how skinny i look husky ethan looks
so skinny
there's dudes that carry it like this
how hardcore are you sucking in right
now as hard as possible
[Laughter]
hard as possible i couldn't carry this
for a long time
daddy
let's get some daddies in the comments
for me
actually i do look pretty skinny though
i'll accept compliment i've been working
really hard on it i've been eating the
most boring
[ __ ] food i've been working my ass
off
drinking lemon water
and not like pleasant lemon water like
really sour [ __ ] up lemon water
where's your daddy what is the purpose
of that
i don't know to him
i'm just curious daddy
i have definitely noticed as i've seen
other people point out though that my
gerd is like way better right it is oh i
haven't even thought about that but it
yeah
that's that's way better yeah this is me
this could be me ela i feel like me and
alex jones weigh the same amount in this
photo
he just carries it different
like a real man
yeah similar [ __ ] ding dong yeah it's
pretty similar actually here this could
be me do you like red me or white me
[Laughter]
like you look the same thing he's just
as fat as me like look my body looks
just like his
and i'm massive yeah you're 40. i've
never sucked
i'm just husky
or him like this
do you think he's sucking in his stomach
right here
yeah
how tall are you i'm like 5 10 5 11.
that's how tall alex jones is so yeah
he is he's 5 10. so he's sucking it in
for sure [ __ ] wow congratulations
you're fat
yeah
so yeah things are going i'm feeling
good actually i'm feeling proud of
myself
to be able to do tips for people weight
loss tips this is alex jones are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you serious
30 years ago
really what's up boy
let's go alex how you doing looks so
different i see the faces
no i see it but he looks extraordinary
different yeah
like if i saw this and didn't know it
was alex jones i wouldn't guess it was
him yeah never
hmm
sucking a ding dong
how do i have weight loss tips no it's
brut the way to lose weight is that it
[ __ ] sucks it's
the hardest thing you'll ever have to do
in your life you're just gonna have to
buck up and just suffer through it
because it's [ __ ] awful
that's my job
that's the tip yep
you're just gonna have to suffer good
you're just gonna have to suffer that's
it that's the truth
how am i gonna keep it off once i lose
it i don't know i have no idea
i have no idea how i could possibly stay
skinny
you don't think you're gaining like good
habits
i am but like i always said that before
when i lost weight too and i just get
fatter than ever
but like for example we ordered a
burrito keep exercising even if you like
lost
weight dude i would like to but honestly
i like working out i feel stronger
but i hate it so much i hate it so
really you don't get any enjoyment out
of it like
you don't get like the euphoria no words
i do not know this euphoria of people
do you what about like just feeling good
about your body
yeah no i love that i love that i feel
confident i feel afterwards like good
like i look better you know so i like
that right
i love that
but the act is just it's horrible it
like ruins my whole day it really does
because i look forward to it
and i'm just like oh [ __ ] i gotta do
this then
i don't know maybe i'm wrong i'd like to
prove myself wrong
but for example on tuesday we ordered
mexican food i had a burrito
didn't eat for the rest of the day
did you guys do that
i don't remember you guys all had gnarly
burritos what did you guys do afterwards
i went home and got bubble tea with lena
and then i ate some cheesecake at the
place don't ask abe yeah well i'm just
curious you all you you guys both had
gnarly burritos too zach yeah it gave me
gnarly sheds too yeah mine wasn't gnarly
remember i i had a i had a veggie
burrito it was like yeah you were you
was but did you eat the rest of the day
zach no i was full okay so so i i think
i was just living like super gnarly
because i would definitely usually eat
another i had another meal after that
but i didn't eat for the rest of the day
that was a plump [ __ ] yeah that was a
huge that was huge
yeah and i finished it by the way i
noticed i was the only one that
literally finished every drop of it
and i had some chips as well
that's what i'm saying i have i have a
disease okay but you made progress you
didn't eat the rest of the day no no i
agree previously you would have
definitely oh yeah what's for dinner
exactly
money
look we like there's nothing wrong with
liking food but that's progress
no there's nothing wrong with liking
crack either but
you shouldn't smoke it
you know
anyway ian what do you do what you would
do in why why do you um in
ian please stand up
stand up here stand up
stand up
[Applause]
round of applause for you did you eat
the rest of the day in
uh no i didn't oh okay interesting so
i was expecting them to say yes i did
only maybe but you know it would be i
didn't have a whole meal either you
still have that like metabolism of like
he's a young man a young man yeah he's
starting to wear but but he didn't even
have a whole meal i noticed he had a
boba and a cake i mean yeah yeah it's
not that crazy
so that tells me
that i because i was expecting they said
i did eat
i was living like a monster
that's one meal
and for me to go home and that's how you
can maintain because when you feel like
you want to eat something like a burrito
you can just don't eat the rest of the
day that never occurred to me before to
be honest with you and the effort that i
made not to eat i felt was personally
heroic
like after i went got through that day
and didn't eat the rest of the day i was
like that was heroic that i was able to
not eat and yet all of you guys
inherently knew not to eat the rest of
the day
well it's like a feel like
when you eat so much it makes you feel
sick you know i was hungry though like
an hour later two hours later before
before you started like your diet what
would be like a go-to meal for you like
a bad just
it could be anything like if there's
frozen pizza
every time you could just make that at
whatever moment you know frozen pizza is
not good so what i do is i take cheese
and black olives i chop it up i add salt
too because it's not salty enough i st
and then i make this whole cheese olive
medley and i put it all over the [ __ ]
pizza so good would you ever like sneak
a mcdonald's like would you go through
that no i i no
i wouldn't sneak food very much
i was sneaking ice cream i was eating a
lot of ice cream
because it was trying the pro also the
problem with this relationship is
either's always trying to gain weight
i'm almost trying to lose weight so she
got the pantry stocked with ice cream
and snacks and all this [ __ ] and every
time i opened the freezer when you put
it away i put it away what else
can i not have a snack
well you put them away and i'm just
checking that pantry now right
what do you want from me nothing i'm
just saying there's a ton of ice cream
in the freezer this is not a pan it's
it's two
things of ice cream my wife still
doesn't believe it i'm not blaming you
and for me it would last a month
but but you come in and he's blaming you
i'm just saying that i sometimes lose
control and eat a whole thing of ice
cream not recently
i got an argument
yeah i'm sorry i mean i got an argument
about this yesterday um for the same
reasons but she just keeps buying like
really unhealthy like honey buns like
the worst thing you could buy
like the dollar really
it's a cheap one it's a bun it's a honey
bun yeah
okay like a sweet like a pastry like a
sweet rice yeah cinnamon rolls donuts
she's buying it for herself or for you
for both of us but i can't resist and
i'm trying i'm trying to lose weight too
so it's a little it's little you guys
got an argument not an argument but just
like uh help me out here
meet me halfway
give me some variety and the snacks
does lena have like a really healthy
relationship with food
i don't know she eats
she eats bad she's the same way as me
but she doesn't gain any weight
whatsoever yeah she probably eats small
portions and then like like with either
she goes we eat the same thing and then
you look at the plate i the burrito was
destroyed i feel like i've stopped
saying that yeah
because i call it started calling eel
out she goes we eat the same thing why
are you gaining so much weight she eats
10 of her burrito i destroy the whole
[ __ ] thing and then start eating hers
speaking of which though friday is my
cheat day
friday baby
[ __ ] should we get him back on the phone
friday baby
i'm kidding well that about wraps it up
i think friday baby
if i could just say this is
my first time in the studio with
everyone oh
right
so how does it feel i'm honored
very cool i hope this doesn't make you
sound like a dude joe rogan's on the fly
it's really it's kind of so real to
finally be at this moment and
should we take care of rogan's call
he's on the line i don't want to be rude
to make him lay
okay what does he have to say he wanted
to compliment us from the new studio and
carry the hatchet yeah oh here he comes
all right joe what's going on man good
to see you
i'm so sick of this guy he just joe why
i don't know why you have to call in and
ruin my show we're having a good time
you play the music it's so arrogant you
say the same stupid thing
all right you want to bury the hatchet
is that why you're calling that about
men who decide they're women who want to
use the girls room [ __ ] roseanne barr
everyone's mad everyone is so mad i
think i've heard this
weird thing i already heard someone
about roseanne is happening that's
distracting the [ __ ] out all right joe
wrap it up
the better guys thank you for watching
you can keep playing it are you going to
explain the hats again because i just
saw some people say like they're not
going to say anything
they're probably joining me
it's fashion what can i say
joe's back on the line he wanted to talk
over me as i close out the show
you don't have to do the whole thing
just play the damn guy talking thank you
peace and love it's the [ __ ] human
interest thank you for watching
everybody we can't get right
i hope you have a great friday it's
friday baby
come on navigating yeah obviously have
problems in business and there's
lawsuits in business
people get fired uh appreciate y'all
coming by
but overall love you guys love our
friends joe right like business joe's
not gonna let me finish she's just gonna
keep talking over me
the guy has no manners at all joe can i
at least close up the show things treat
each other no we barely get better at
that ugh i can't barely talk over this
guy so i'm gonna wrap it up because he
just won't shut the [ __ ] up someone for
doing something that's the word anyway
guys uh with like
i'll just leave you with joe i guess
thanks for watching
everybody was like no [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
all this weird personal interaction [ __ ]
is happening that's distracting the [ __ ]
out of us the more it ramps up
the better ai
it's like we're we're falling into this
whole like if this was a trap if i was
artificial intelligence
and i knew i'd be like well
is what we'll do we'll just go back in
time and set people up and make them
make us
we'll just plant this idea in their
heads and just like well the ass is the
way to go because it's like open and
it's not like you don't go through the
dermis
just connects with you and you [ __ ]
see augmented reality with a little tiny
robot dick
[Music]
you